good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy
friday friday gotta get down on friday
so excited to announce that it is friday
and that we have so much weekend ahead
of us
and it's all right in front of us you
guys so breathe it in breathe
on it vibe it we've been waiting all day
for friday night so
exciting that it's friday so exciting to
have another episode of the toast
another beautiful snow day it started
snowing on our way in so
hopefully again the snow was falling in
the background i know a lot of you loved
that vibe yesterday
walking in a winter wonderland
um how was your day my day was good i'm
wearing new redheads merch so i just
want to say like a little backstory
about this sweater because i haven't had
a chance to wear it yeah which is such a
shame
because when it's a shonda because when
we started
the redheads and we made the logo i have
been dreaming of this cream sweater
for a year like i just thought the logo
on a creamy vibe was just going to be
the cutest sweater
and it is and i just hadn't had a chance
it's so cute for a number of different
reasons and i just love this sweater so
much
shopmorningtoast.com it is still
available and
i think it's like my favorite sweater in
my entire closet wow those are no
powerful words
no shade to the maroon one of course not
and no shade
it's a year in the making it's also a
it's a
a physical tangible expression of your
passion hundred percent and that's
jackie that's beautiful thank you
claudia also the craziest thing happened
to me this morning and i feel like
i i obviously need to tell you and i
feel like you're gonna realize that it's
so crazy
this morning i had the same uber driver
that i had yesterday
and yesterday when i had him he he like
has picked me up before and that's
something that started to happen to me
i've
been having just like the same uber
drivers because my morning routine is
like
in line with their morning routine but
then and we were chatting yesterday
about how it was funny that
um he's picked you up he's picked me up
and i even got his um
card for private driving yeah you know i
never need a ride
and then this morning he picked me up
again that's [ __ ] weird i know when
we were laughing he was like it's
because we're the only two people
working
no literally the city so it used to be
the biggest city now it's so small it is
so small and that's over the last six
months
i have had like the same uber driver a
number of times like different of the
same like a lot of different uber
drivers
but to have back to back is really crazy
well i think
it's crazy and it's a it's crazy in an
uber but i think to have the same yellow
cab what
twice is insanity and it's happened to
me once really and
did the driver remember you yes but it's
because like
my drive with him the first time was so
memorable and how long apart were the
two drives
in the same year wow because
i we used to take the subway to school
but like when we were running light like
we would take a cab
and i remember one morning i was running
really really late it was you had
already you and olivia had already
graduated and margo wasn't in high
school yet so i was traveling alone we
used to travel together
and i had like a really traumatic
experience on this
cab drive up to school because um i
forgot my credit card
and i was like freaking out and when he
pulled up to school i'm like oh my god i
forgot my credit card i'm like let me
just run
in like i could borrow money from one of
my friends and whatever
instead of letting me out the cab driver
locked the doors and made a u-turn
on park avenue and i was literally 15
years old and i was hysterically crying
in the back of the car do you not know
the story
no i was hysterically crying in the back
of the cab like freaking out
and then i realized he was taking me
back to where he picked me up
i guess to go get my credit card but
like the whole locking and i just didn't
know what was going on it was so scary
so when i finally arrived at school i
was like traumatized they're about to
write me a late notice and i'm like miss
malami like i literally was just
abducted like i was hysterically crying
i had to talk to the psychologist
whatever so that afternoon i was like
[ __ ] this i'm taking a cowboy
and i took a cab home and i just really
like vented to the cab driver about my
really traumatic experience and he was
so kind and then like a year later he
was like
he picks me up from school again same
block and he was like i think i picked
you up before like were you the girl
crying and i'm like yeah
so it was the second captain yes not the
first one twice
wow that is a really crazy story i know
i was shaking in the back of this cab
like
so afraid but like that's just living in
new york you know getting abducted on
your way to school
yes that is that really is it that's new
york i was never really in any harm
no but you just didn't know what was
like where you were and he wouldn't tell
me i'm like where are you taking me i
was so afraid
you know like those moments in life
where like it becomes really real that
like you could die
yeah like sometimes on a plane that
happens it like you get this huge lump
in your throat
of course and i realized like in times
of trouble some people like our heroes
and some people are just
stagnant and i'm stagnant i couldn't
move like i was
frozen yeah well at least you know that
about yourself
yeah no it was actually an important
lesson to learn at a young age
and now like every time i'm in like one
of those situations i'm like i'm gonna
be that girl i always like to think like
if i was on the subway and there was
like
something happening like i would be the
hero you know but
i probably wouldn't yeah it's nice
that's an interesting thing to think
about
everyone thinks they'll be a hero you
know but then it's like when push comes
to shove your body just freezes in those
moments you know it reminds me of a
quote from a book the nightingale
i'm gonna botch it but it's along the
lines of in love you find out who you
want to be
in war you find out who you are yeah
because in war
i'm a big big [ __ ] i'm a big one
i'm really really scared of everything
um we have an amazing show
we do and also yesterday we interviewed
norma kamali fashion designer icon queen
and now
author we were talking all about her
book and all of her life lessons
right and first of all the concept of
her book was so interesting like it's
she's in her 70s now and she was like
here's everything you learned in your
20s your 30s your 40s your 50s your 60s
or 70s
and i feel like she gave some really
good advice to us and to our listeners
she really really did i felt very
inspired after talking to her also i was
like all dressed up for the interview my
blazer yesterday was
molly i'm just a huge fan of her designs
and so it was really exciting to talk to
her but also i felt
very inspired after speaking with her
and i feel like the toasters will feel
the same way
by the way me too because i am now
inspired like during coven
especially after cover to just like live
my life to the fullest like jump off a
cliff and she was like
you guys have to she's talking to like
us and our you know generation
generation like
we have to make up for last year that's
not how i was looking at it before we
spoke to her i was like you know what
this year is a wash like we'll carry on
when it's over
but no like we have to double down on
living as she said
when we can and and those weren't my
plans before
no me neither but the more she said i'm
like you're right like we've been robbed
of
a really important year for us yeah and
you can't just let it go on that way
like you have to make up for it like i
want to be exhausted by the end of this
year
right so i think them some good lessons
yeah no i'm actually already planning
trips i just want to warn everyone like
the toast will be very spotty when
things come back because
i already have a trip planned in june
and who knows where else you know i'm
going to go for the rest of the year i
just like have plans
no i think that's so great but also what
this year has shown us is that we really
can do the show virtually
yeah remember when you were on tour and
every time it was a struggle either
we were like what what's gonna be of the
show yeah but
either i had to find a co-host or we did
a few times like where i would facetime
you and record your audio like
so crazy but now we really can do it
remotely so i think that get
now that we know that we can enjoy
the fruits of our country yeah we were
here when we needed to be
and then sayonara um so yes we have that
and then we're also going to be
recapping our toast movie of the week
which was cinderella which i actually
have a lot of thoughts on that i didn't
think that i would have
so that'll be in our tv recap segment
and then next week is our final
it's the final week of february aka
black history month so we have one more
movie we're going to watch if you have
any recommendations feel free to send
them to us because we have not chosen it
yet and we're going to be choosing it on
monday
yes also just like one update personal
update last night i cooked
a recipe from ina garten's cookbook not
the modern comfort cookbook from her how
easy is that cookbook someone gave it to
me
and i made her lemon chicken and it was
so amazing really
so keto i literally like it serves like
four to six
there's two pieces left like zach loved
it i loved it i ate so much of it and it
was like
free keto food right i was so pleased
and that was the first iron recipe that
i've cooked
that i've really enjoyed right because
you were turnt on her i was a little
turnt on her i was like maybe aina and i
have completely different palettes
right and you know what that's just a
fact of life right and i
i do think you need to find chefs who
you agree with
yeah i think i agree with the pioneer
woman i've been following her on tick
tock and first of all her lifestyle is
just
everything like yeah get you a girl who
could do both like you know saddle the
ranch and then like make you linguine's
clams
and she like loves her kids so much
she's like a bunch of daughters and i
just think like
i want to be here when i go yeah a lot
of the toaster said like that's me when
i grow up yeah and it's like
goals she has a blog and it was like so
successful she got her own food network
show and like now she lives on a ranch
and she just like does super well
i don't know where all this wealth comes
from is it the blog is it food network
is it family money like what does her
husband do like i don't even care i just
like i'm living for the wealth
yes goals goals
goals goals goals um so we have like
decent stories today i mean we do
by the end of the week it's friday like
all the good stories are gone and we're
just like here talking about random [ __ ]
but you know what
those are the best episodes those are
the best episodes and and you know there
are some things to discuss today so i
think we need to get into
the fast five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast
i just realized i've been like hurdled
over like my posture like a hermit okay
let me just sit up straight because i
want to put respect on the name of this
brand
today's episode is brought to you by the
one and only
bruce yes yes that would have been
embarrassing if i got it wrong bruce is
one of our favorite sponsors we talk
about them multiple times a week it is
the best electric toothbrush on the
market it is so elegant it is so chic
and
most of all it works super well and it's
the most reasonably priced
electric toothbrush i've ever seen and
it's so much prettier than the ones that
cost over 200
i'm like you cost over 200 you are ugly
as hell yeah the bruce is so elegant it
comes in amazing colors the brush itself
works so well
and for an electric toothbrush it is
very reasonably priced so the brush
itself comes with six unique
unique cleaning modes to customize your
brushing experience the battery life
lasts four weeks so if you're going on a
trip
you don't need to bring the charger
unless you're going away for more than a
month which
jealous if you are um the magnetic
charging stand is so elegant
and it comes with a compact travel case
they also have a subscription program so
you never forget to change your brush
head again
they'll ship you a new replacement head
every six months so you're never stuck
with a worn down brush head
which can lead to bad breath bad dental
hygiene um and using electric toothbrush
is a sustainable way of the future it is
much more environmentally friendly
um their designs are very sleek they
have a modern aesthetically pleasing
design
and it comes in trend driven seasonal
colors and looks great on your bathroom
counter
so you could always be checking the
website for the new seasonal colors
everything of the sort i have them like
millennial blush pink stunning and i'm
really happy with it because i have like
rolls gold accents in my bathroom and
it's just like a very
um like l woods vibe you know what it
matches your book
oh my god it does get 15 off your brush
toothbrush kit and refill plan when you
use the promo code toast
at bruce.com that's 15 off using code
toast at brush dot com
promo code toast bruce dot com love it
sign on brush your teeth i just wanted
to point to my new phone case
it is oh and my new manicure it is the
how you dern this is the uh
hard case right yeah i love the hard
cases it's like the one that has double
protection because remember when i
cracked my screen last year and then had
a broken phone for six months like with
this double case
oh we're both using them so that's the
redheads phone case
and this is the uh hyudern forrest green
phone case also comes in white
but they are available at
shopmorningtoast.com for any phone
galaxy iphone any size so check it out
so beautiful yes yeah any phone size
yes okay are you ready for the things i
pride
myself on like about our business like
we literally have phone cases for any
phone like i think we literally even
sell our flip phones
yes for sure are you ready for our
stories first story the big news of the
day mr big will not be in the sex in the
city reboot
page six has learned that chris noth
will not reprise reprise his role chris
nother kristen
well it's probably no since i said noth
i think i just say no
okay but i have no evidence evidentiary
support
page six has learned that chris will not
reprise his role as the iconic mr big in
the sex and the city reboot
they're also told that david eigenberg
who played miranda hobbs love interest
steve brady won't be returning
either [ __ ] serious but a rep told
page six on thursday that the actor is
in negotiations to appear in the series
oh my god first of all okay there's so
much to unpack here
especially because i don't know if i've
mentioned i've started re-watching
i'm on like season five already i watch
it every night ben loves it and it's
just like a great show
and it really is like a study for me of
just this really interesting television
show that is for some reason making a
comeback when
literally nobody wants to be a part of
it and the more i watch the more i
realize okay the show is literally
carried by samantha
and miranda charlotte too but really
samantha miranda samantha's not going to
be there
love love love the episodes with mr big
like i actually sometimes skip
relationships like i just skipped burger
because it's so painful
and so big is one of my favorite
relationships that was aiden big's none
of it
somebody on our instagram left a comment
it's totally unfounded by evidentiary
support
but they were like there's been a rumor
for a while that they're gonna kill off
mr big which is
[ __ ] crazy but if you think about it
how can they not have a minute what
carrie gets divorced
right after everything we've been
through in the last two movies like they
didn't end up together that's such a
good point the only way
out for him is to die and steve
is literally my favorite character he's
right so funny and like i'm just
re-watching and
with a new mature lens and knowing that
we're getting the show back with
literally the characters we didn't ask
for aka carrie
it's very upsetting yeah i know but you
know what these new
this news just makes me feel even better
about my decision to not be watching
i was gonna watch but now it's like it
seems like carrie
sarah jessica parker like wants to do it
and like they're just gonna do it
because she wants to do it
even though all the other people have
really moved on in their lives like at
some point like you just have to stop
beating a dead horse right and i don't
think that the people involved in the
show realize that
carrie is the worst part of the show
like they think that she's a star as
long as it's carrie
right now he is there right svp
i said sjp oh i said svp um
but that's not no you're right you're
right like they think that it's cat
obviously she's the protagonist the show
she's on board but that's not it's
nothing of the sword yeah i actually
really want to urge the creators
to really reconsider this like you know
when you did the two movies
it was a bargain but you know what i
actually really enjoyed them even though
they weren't great movies
but i do think like at this point you
are going to
put the legacy of the show in jeopardy
and it's like really not worth it
and i just i beg you to reconsider
especially now knowing that so many
people do not want to be a part of it
kim catrell
chris noth steve like are you [ __ ]
kidding me what is this show without
steve
yeah and how would he not be in it tell
me him and miranda broke up again so
we're just ruining all the happy endings
right we've been pointing this is why i
want to stay and where we're at i don't
want to know what happens after the
second movie if this if these are the
changes they're going to be making
yeah and especially with stephen and
miranda i feel like to break them up is
just like it sends a bad message
like they were really i think of all the
couples the realest one like they had
the most real lives you know yeah they
dealt with real issues like
carrie is like you know she's not really
never has to pay her bills and big just
like buys her an apartment like
that's not real life like miranda and
steve like that is a real relationship
and if they break up like
i will actually be so annoyed yeah i
agree and i don't know how many reboots
need to fail before the people in charge
realize that
they are nothing of the sort yeah but i
do feel like this is something that's
just going to have to play itself out
it's you have a lesson you have to learn
the hard way yeah
and it really makes me sad to think that
we are living in like you know the
the peak of science and math and
creativity and like
somehow hollywood has all the money in
the world and they just continue to
remake things and don't get me wrong
some of the remakes are good but it's
like can anyone have an original idea
anymore
no they really can't like even like the
shows that have gotten so popular like
bridgerton based off a book queen's
gambit based off a book okay but based
off a book is fine by me
one gossip girl was based off a book
because the city is based that's true
but like hollywood has not come up with
something original no but they need to
like
keep basing things off of books i think
that's a really great road to go down
because i read so many books i'm like oh
this would make an amazing movie
but then they make the movie and it's
garbage yeah i'm just saying like even
though
it's good i like when they do things
based off of movies it's interesting to
know that we're living at like you know
it's never been more technologically
creatively advanced and hollywood can't
come up with their own original thought
whether it's a movie or a reboot i'm a
book or a reboot like
why don't you come try something new
start from scratch yeah but if you know
all else fails stick to the books
yeah i do often read i mean i can't
believe they haven't made um
an evelyn hugo movie movie because it's
like
so good they might yeah it takes time
these things i really enjoyed that book
yes but even like game of thrones book
book yep twilight book i mean
it's all the boys i love book did you
watch the third one no not yet i haven't
really been watching the teaching booth
was the book too but i cannot get into
my whole spiel about the kissing booth i
don't have the time today i'm telling
you i can't i haven't watched a lot of
tv
recently but i think this weekend i'm
going to pick back up downton abbey
bruce and i started an episode yesterday
and that's his favorite show of
everything that i watch
so i just want to give him that that's
so funny theo's favorite show is friends
right and that's so theo
so theo even though i haven't watched
friends in a few months you know i got
to take breaks to keep it fresh
yeah i feel that i had i took a really
long break from downton abbey i don't
know i just got busy
i feel that but um we're i'm getting
back in it's just so good
oh and i have to catch up on rupaul's
drag race before tonight i'm actually so
excited oh that's exciting
oh also today is like the best day to
just stay home
yes watch the morning toast and all your
shows
not that you would make it a story
because i know you don't watch but so
last season on rupaul's drag race there
was a contestant
whose name was sherry pie and she was
super talented
and she was never on the show like she
was there the whole time we never got to
hear her critiques we never got
testimonials from her and it was like
they literally cut her out of the show
and it turns out um that after they
filmed but before the show aired
there was like 12 people who came
forward with allegations of catfishing
sexual assault and that's why they cut
him out of the show
then tamron hall announced last week
that she was gonna have him on her show
and there was so much backlash like you
know give your platform to the victims
instead of the
perpetrator but he went on she aired the
interview it was like 15 minutes and it
was
really bizarre um but he just like came
out and said like yeah i did all of that
like i have bpd like he said i'm not
blaming my mental illness
but it was like a really weird interview
but what i thought was most interesting
was cameron
before the show did like a solo
monologue addressing a lot of the
backlash that she got
and she was like i am a reporter i'm a
journalist like i have interviewed
rapists murderers you know her sister
was murdered and she was like i would
even interview the man who was accused
of murdering my sister so
i thought like her whole spiel like
addressing the backlash was actually
really um an interesting take on it but
it was like a crazy weird saga that i
was a part of because i was watching
last season that it now finally came to
an end
and it was it was a really bizarre
interview
wow i didn't know that tamarind had him
on but i do remember when everything
went down as last season was airing yes
crazy
crazy okay next story some love
is in the air news love is in the air l
every sunday what's that
that's a song and love is in the air
you know that song keeps going look it
up
love is in the air and i don't wanna run
around
that's a song no you're singing like the
tune of a song yeah but the
love is in the air i don't know
well it sounds like a good song so if it
doesn't exist you should record it no it
totally i think it goes like this
love is in the air and wanna where i
wanna ram
you know something like that it's like
from those movies you know you know what
the good news is if it is a song someone
will like let you know what you're
trying to
get out yeah just jump in the comments
love is in the air
[Music]
something like that okay michael b
jordan says i love you to girlfriend
lori harvey in a sweet post of their
night out oh that's cute i saw these
pictures like
stunning find me two better looking
people no i know and also like their
valentine's
day was like the peak of romance
everything at the store so
many flowers everywhere you looked
flowers flowers flowers and on thursday
the black panther actor shared some new
photos of him and his girlfriend from
their night out
writing i love you baby in the caption
so this is big news like because we
reported a few weeks ago that they're
together then they were literally on a
ship
yeah and now they're in love which is so
special
yeah i mean there are all these
conspiracy theories that it's like a pr
relationship but i just refuse to
believe
it because this is just such a pairing
you know hollywood elite royalty
lori harvey and you know heartbreaker
man of everyone's dreams michael b
jordan
that it just makes too much sense to be
a setup i i really believe that
i really believe it too where is this
aquarium do you know no idea
it was just such a beautiful evening
yeah and i'm so happy to see that
they're in love i hope that this
relationship like
i hope they're together like all the
flowers that they
like yeah just beautiful i would love to
um like learn more about them like i
would i know they would never but like
that's the type of couple i would watch
a reality show on
oh my god a hundred percent i just i
actually feel like the life of lori
harvey is so interesting
steve harvey is so [ __ ] rich like you
never met someone so rich in your life
and he just comes from this like and she
comes from this like a royal hollywood
family
and i would just love to know more
actually i really feel like the harvey's
would be good for reality i don't think
it's so out of the question like it
probably wouldn't happen but it's not
so far-fetched it's not so far-fetched i
think now that laurie harvey is dating
michael b jordan like she might have
be she might be beyond it but i think
before that they really have such an
interesting life like marjorie is like a
huge philanthropist
steve doesn't stop working like his
radio show his talk show
family feud like literally miss america
he's
ryan seacrest on like 10 times and
actually
and they have a lot of kids so i
actually think that's a really great
platform for them did you see the
commercials for the new
show for real hosted by annie cohen it's
like
yes yeah that looks great yeah it does
look good he
it's basically like a docu-series where
he is talking to
reality stars and and sort of going like
i'm assuming each episode will be
dedicated to a different reality show
where he like gets all the behind the
scenes oh i thought a different reality
star
no i think a show oh interesting and so
he'll get
like the genesis time like not just like
this age
no it's like from survivor to vanderpump
rules
right i thought it was such an
interesting concept for a show maybe i
only think that because i would
literally like smell andy cohen's farts
like i would do
like i don't care um but it did look
really good and he's the perfect person
for it yeah it looks really good so
that's exciting
uh for real yeah for real speaking of
love news and reality shows
dale moss says he has a lot to smile
about after reuniting with ex claire
crawley
uh you guys are clarindale back together
dale is all smiles after he was spotted
reuniting with ex-fiance claire crawley
the clarendale that's so funny no it
reminds me of frozen
yeah of course the former bachelorette
contestant who announced his split from
claire last month shared a photo of
himself on his instagram story with the
caption
a lot to smile about lately two days
before his optimistic post
he and claire hung out at nakomo sunset
hut bar in florida according to photos
obtained by tmz
the pair spent time at the bar before
heading out and walking down to the
nearby waterfront the outlay reported
okay this i didn't not see coming and i
really think the only thing
sadder than the way things happened is
if they get back together
yeah to me this is not tracking for what
i had thought so maybe i need to
rejigger what i thought
because what i thought was like dale was
like coerced into this relationship
like was really not into claire and got
out the second that he could
so if that's the case you don't go back
to that person no so i'm confused now
i'm confused too but i thought that no i
think that
like dale obviously things didn't play
out the way he imagined but i think that
he had feelings for claire
and let's see where things go but it
felt like he was unfaithful to her and
dishonest with her and so like what is
she doing with him once again
oh well and then if that's the case and
there was a real estate agent
if that's the case my respect for claire
all the way down
right like come on i don't know yeah so
i i do want happiness for her and
like if this is it i'll the thing is
respect it but i just
i feel like it's just like she was
disrespected right i want happiness for
her too but at this point like i
really do not trust her judgment when it
comes to relationships like that's what
i learned from
her chaotic energy on her season and
that's sad
that is the truth and that's what we do
here this is the morning truth
yeah and some of those truths are hard
they are they're very hard
very hard okay next story little royal
news that i'm confused about
okay prince harry and meghan markle
confirmed they won't return to royal
rules the queen says
all are saddened like is this one year
ago how is this new news but it's
everywhere
breaking news well because mexi was like
supposed to be a temporary break they're
stepping back
that with the implication that you could
step forward again and now it's like
i think i i assume that too but this is
like a full confirmation that it's like
they're out for good okay i thought megs
it was for good
i guess i did too i don't know how
you're going to step out and step back
in like how you do maybe you just needed
a break like i think maybe people
thought that this was a break but
they're laying down roots in calabasas
and netflix like disney plus
they are so never going back and i think
they've gotten a taste
for the civilian life their version of
civilian and it's too delicious to pass
up all the money
yeah it's not civilian it's hollywood
royalty they went from still civilian
yeah like you don't have royal duties to
your country no of course not but it's
a-list like
civilians no their version of civilian
like
my version of civilian and harry and
megan's are just like kind of different
you know not that different well megan
and harry will officially not be
returning to their royal
roles buckingham palace confirmed in a
statement on friday as was speculated
the couple who left full-time royal work
in march of last year
will no longer keep their patronages aka
their royal involvement with numerous uk
charities the duke and duchess of sussex
have confirmed her majesty the queen
that that will not be returning as
working members of the royal family the
statement continued from buckingham
palace
following the conversations with the
duke the queen has written confirming
that stepping
that in stepping away from the work of
the royal family it is not possible to
continue with the responsibilities and
duties that come with a life of public
service and
i'm sure they're like oh no right we
have a question
i mean i think colloquially i think
that's the word like i will always refer
to prince harry as prince harry because
like his first name is prince and his
last name is harry like that's just
i was just going to say this too but i
never really got into the habit of
calling megan the duchess of sussex
right
um so she'll just be meghan markle to me
but do they technically have the titles
i think they are still the duke and
duchess of sussex i don't think
calling him prince harry makes any sense
anymore okay but like he likes prince
harry
colloquially yes he's prince harry he
that's how we
call him harry yeah harry and megan
harry windsor
okay harry windsor is just like never
going to catch on for me no i mean
obviously
whatever you want but like he's really
not prince harry no but like is the
media going to be referring to him as
prince harry or i mean
what does headline say prince harry see
right some things just don't go away
it's like a nickname but it's like a
nickname yeah but there can really only
be one prince of america
prince who's that prince oh the singer
okay i didn't know like i thought you
might say like joe jonas like oh of
course
sorry there could only be two princes
i'm sorry i [ __ ] up joe jonas and
prince
yes um no this is like crazy but it's
also like we already knew that like
we've been expecting this i never
thought they would be going back but i
guess
in terms of like the way that the crown
has to release information like this was
the next step like
i'm sure they knew a year ago they said
okay you'll leave and then we'll release
another statement in 2021
yeah saying we'll break it up yeah make
it like less of a scandal even though
what
when it all happened last year it
couldn't have been bigger news right
are you ready for our fifth and final
story because my ipad is dying oh [ __ ]
yeah but also i can't believe mexi was
only a year ago like i know
truly six lifetimes ago we were in the
old studio sorry
go finish your ipad demi lovato has
brain damage after suffering three
strokes and a heart attack following her
2018 overdose
demi lovato is telling it all on
wednesday youtube premiered the trailer
for demi lovato dancing with the devil
a documentary series about her near
fatal 2018 drug overdose and the effects
it had on lovato's life
the trailer gives the first look into
what the 28 year old sanctus faced after
being hospitalized
she also reveals that she had three
strokes and a heart attack in the
hospital
damn damn um i watched the trailer it
was like three minutes actually looked
very titillating yeah i saw the
beginning where she was like i'll just
say everything and if we want to cut it
out yeah
and it seems like they didn't cut
anything out right because they left
that in right i love the title dancing
with the devil me too and i love her
sister who played juanita on desperate
housewives and she's in it
um so that's why i'll be watching but i
do think it's
i've always said this about demi lovato
i think like the way that she has a lot
of young fans but like is always really
open and transparent about her struggles
with addiction and substance abuse
is super super admirable and it seems
like in this documentary it's no
different like she's going really deep
yeah and we all we all knew you know
what we were here when it happened we
knew the information that we were given
i had no idea that it was this bad that
it was like
near death yeah and like she's still
suffering
you know from the complications yes the
incident
i agree i appreciate that she's always
so honest with her fans i
think that's something it's one of the
best things it's one of the best things
about her and something that we get
really frustrated with other people
about like that
they say one thing and do another and i
always appreciate her honesty
she's released documentaries and i think
in the last 10 years there's been
two other ones and then in each
documentary she's like oh well in the
last one it wasn't totally
true true because of this and that she
said that in the last one about the one
before it yeah
and i mean she can release whatever she
wants and she is always like being
honest in the moment
but i it is frustrating to like know
that like
she she could come on this documentary
be like well i was lying in the last one
right
yeah but that's but that honestly i feel
like even though it's frustrating as a
viewer i feel like that's honestly
parallel to what it's like to like know
someone or live with someone who
struggles with addiction yeah
but i agree it also is a lot she's been
through so much it's a lot of
documentaries three documentaries for
someone who's i don't even think she's
30 yet i imagine documentaries are so
like emotional and painful and you just
like excavate everything about yourself
yeah but maybe they're also therapeutic
i yeah actually i could see them being
both that is therapy
you know yeah but also like for me i
would like not want to sit down and
watch what
all these other people have to say about
me like oh that's how you feel cool yeah
and then you have to go back to being
like friends with them yeah and it's
like even i know what you said about me
in your documentary
yeah that's an interesting process
yeah i actually love celebrity
documentaries i feel like we talk about
this a lot
some of my favorites are gaga 5'2 um
one of the other ones that i like i
could post them up yeah i feel like
we've done this before but
i just always remember oh no that's
still lady gaga five for two um
i actually really really just like that
one it's on netflix and it's like
leading up to her performance at the
super bowl
which was just like you know a huge
mental physical um emotional journey for
her totally so here are some that i know
that you watched
miss americana of course loved it so
much sorry i cannot believe i just
forgot it i apologize to the swifties
loved it so much because it was a
documentary with a purpose yes amy did
you watch that one
no i started on a plane once i couldn't
get into it i watched [ __ ] it was really
sad katy perry remember when she had a
documentary
and she was getting divorced okay that
is part of me right
yes is such a good documentary and you
know what it aired in theaters
yes it did i saw it through me too one
direction of course i've actually
watched it recently so cute uh gaga five
foot two
unbelievable justin bieber never say
never did you watch that one no but that
was also a half
concert yeah so was actually the one
direction and the katy perry
were half concert half documentary yes
i'm trying there's oh joan rivers piece
of work
oh iconic the best piece of work
ever i actually own it on youtube i
don't know where else you can watch it
but i highly recommend you buying it
because i feel like it's going to be
gone soon it is so delicious
if you ever want to understand like why
we have such an appreciation
for jones comedy her work ethic her
legacy
that's your homework this weekend watch
joe nervous piece of work you will laugh
and you will cry and it also chronicles
around the same time where she's on
celebrity apprentice and she spoiler
alert wins
and it's just such there's so much
happening it's so good
yeah also some other ones that we
haven't watched but that look really
good
whitney uh talking about whitney houston
um hold on
there's so many i mean michael jackson
this is it was a really big one
also i watched one another i watched a
different michael jackson documentary
that i actually found
more interesting yes me as well well we
watched the paris hilton documentary
oh loved that yes you know who just put
out a documentary too and i haven't
heard anything was
ariana grande her sweetener tour but
then
on netflix right yeah which i haven't
heard anything about but then remember
we watched dangerous woman
it was like the youtube one yeah yeah
that one was pretty good oh also seasons
justin bieber was good youtube does
really good youtube
does demi does paris they do good
documentaries i never watched seasons
but i heard it was really good it was
i watched the episodes about the wedding
because they were like so stunning
yeah i feel like there are so many more
but that was just the list i saw yeah if
you're a celebrity like keep releasing
documentaries oh one that i actually
really do documentaries or memoirs like
they i think they both accomplish the
same thing one that i really really
really didn't like that will like really
piss off the stanhood but i'm like
feeling like starting drama today
shawn mendes is wonder first of all
like the home stuff i really didn't like
we get it you're humble like what else
is there like it was just like
i love to hang out with my friends from
high school like okay what else like we
get it yeah you're modest you're round
to earth like
down to earth can you do something else
now um
and then the concert i actually realized
uh i don't know any shawn mendes songs
like i know like the five that are on
the radio
but like i don't know any from his album
like i know okay the
the you know the early ones stitches
okay um the big party one
like something big yeah yeah that is
like a song he doesn't stand by but
that's like his first song after mine
and i thought that was an amazing song
okay
something big i feel it happening okay
so in the blood
no in my blood yeah stitches
um it's something big that doesn't count
okay
um oh i know i can't run a song that's
not about
you yeah
uh wonder such a [ __ ] good song
wonder such a good [ __ ] song
uh hold on let me just go to my spot if
i saved songs so it was like a 45 minute
concert and i'm like what are these
songs i've never heard them before
yeah um but he is so handsome like that
oh he has a song on the descendant
soundtrack i was just about to say
what are we calling we're not calling
those shirts
white tank tops that boys wear we're not
i can't believe by the way forever that
they were called those
yeah what are they called white tank top
i guess yeah pains
yeah that's lined yeah um oh my god you
know what i just realized like
for most of my life they've been
regarded as
you can just i'm not saying it you can
say so people know what you're talking
about
w-i-f-e-b-e-a yeah okay here's a um
e-r what are we calling them
yeah here someone else's question [ __ ]
made up that name there's a more
appropriate term i can use in place of
the w word here in the us um
here are some tank top singlets but
that's an australian term a sleeveless
shirt or an undershirt
undershirt
so it's a tank top undershirt yeah we
just need to come up with a word so that
we know what we're referring to we
should come up with it
okay uh tankini like a a rib top
yeah it's ripped yeah yeah yeah whatever
he was wearing the whole time it was so
hot and that was a silver lining but i
actually really did not like the
documentary that was the uh
tangent that was the moral of the story
yes okay um
are you gonna watch demi's yeah probably
like if i get bored enough
yeah even though i'm not like a huge
demi lovato fan like i always support
her and her music is
like numb it's fine um but i like i
think she's a great role model
yeah i watched the last one i was really
moved by me too
and um she was just like open as [ __ ] i
know just like my content
like i would like to watch it i just
know that i'm not going to yeah and you
know i was actually thinking about the
other day did you ever watch
ben platt's netflix special i feel like
you didn't no i didn't
isn't that crazy because like we're such
because i was like so excited about it
but i honestly feel like emotionally i
can't
handle it it's it's actually really
emotional i just like i can't go there
did you see that um video that went
viral on tick tock
of the couple that they're writing a gay
couple dancing to ben platts
um share your dress they made up like a
choreographed dance no that's so cute
but i'm not saying i don't
see so cute then put it on his instagram
that's why i thought maybe you would see
it send it to me
it's really cute cute um okay let's dive
into our tv recap segment where we are
recapping one movie every week for toast
movie of the week in honor of black
history month
and this month we i mean this week we
chose cinderella rogers and hammerstein
cinderella starring brandi and whitney
houston
to celebrate you know more black
representation in disney movies because
it makes a really big impact on young
children
yes and i was really excited to watch it
and i think it's important for everyone
to remember like you have to set your
expectations because
it's made for tv yeah and it was made
early 2000s
yeah like probably 20 years ago so the
special effects like with that you know
pumpkin rolling down the hill like
making it like it was really
you know it reminded me of paint on
windows 98 like just really
old school but there was so much about
the movie to love
and for me like that was whitney houston
100
and my biggest critique of the movie is
like we didn't get enough not
enough whitney and i feel like this is i
guess the issue just with cinderella
this story is like fairy godmother is
only in one scene so
she could they they really maxed out how
she even followed her in the character
yeah
like she was like let me in like she she
wanted in the movie as much as she could
get she showed up at the end of the
night
yeah to have a little girl chat wow
and then she's saying the last song at
the end so they did as much with whitney
as they possibly could have
but it is like a fatal flaw of the movie
that she's not in more scenes
because i could have watched that
impossible scene all
night long i was literally screaming at
the top of my lungs impossible
impossible impossible
like i was just living for it and i just
could have watched that
whole you know pumpkin dress singing
impossible
i could have watched that forever
forever and it was also really shocked
at how
starshine of the movie was queen king
whippy goldberg and victor
victor
on point on point um jason alexander i
thought was a miscast
you know he was i think he was trying to
bring like lefou energy like
you know i'm so clumsy like everyone's
always stepping on me
and it just was not translating for me
and i feel like he
suffers you know from a hollywood curse
when you're
too good at your job you'll always have
the thing that made you famous you'll
always be that character but then he's
in shallow how
and he's his shallow hal character is so
similar to george costanza like did you
see her toe like it's like the same
stupid humor
yeah that's why it was like the only
role in my opinion that he was ever
really good at after seinfeld
because he's so costanza so like why is
george costanza in france or wherever
this movie takes place you know yeah
yeah it made no sense i just felt like
he
didn't i don't know it didn't work for
me there were some like it was very
lefou but i also could have seen it
being like stanley tucci like
oh yeah so that was
a miss for me i feel that bernadette
peters was great and i didn't know
either of the characters who played the
step sisters but i thought they were
great
they were hysterical they were
hysterical and brandy of course
was just a star like so beautiful not
wearing an ounce of makeup like couldn't
have looked more stunning
and also i didn't know who the um prince
was and i guess he never got famous
he never got famous after i think this
was like his first film because in the
credits
introducing yeah yeah but i guess it
wasn't but i thought he did a really
good job
yeah i think he was okay yeah he was
cute he was very made for tv
you know i didn't think whitney or
brandy or like bernadette peters were
giving me made for tv energy no but then
it was like there were commercial breaks
in the middle
yeah i was wondering why i kept going to
black but you told me afterwards that it
was made for tv
yeah which also explains like the uh
the editing the editing and also just
like the set yeah
the set was a little wonky right because
it was like a tv set it wasn't like a
major blockbuster
budget right yeah i guess i just
remembered you know watching it
as a kid and you know when you're a kid
and this was like 20 years ago
you have lower expectations obviously
and everything is so fantastical
but now it's like i've seen beauty and
the beast live action like this budget
this special effects was like so wonky
but it didn't take away from the
specialness of watching
you know brandy and whitney houston on
screen together but the one thing i will
say and
maybe not about this movie but about the
cinderella story in general
is that i understand it's meant for kids
but as an adult like i could only play
dumb for so long there were so many
things that weren't adding up
okay so the prince met brandi
in town right and then she showed up in
a dressing with her hair up and he
didn't recognize her okay maybe you know
he only met her once whatever
her own stepsisters and stepmother
didn't know her like that was so stupid
and i could only
and i actually don't think kids are even
that dumb like i think the kids would be
like mommy
well they know her they live with her
like you know what i mean
yeah it's so stupid yeah and there was
just like so much like
so many okay another thing like so many
flaws in the storyline
so he goes to try on the glass slippery
with everyone and he's at the house
bernadette peters and her two girls try
it on
and then he goes is there someone else
in the house how the [ __ ] would he know
that
yeah he's like how does he know
so there was just like so much like
convenience for the storyline yeah and
of course like i think everyone harps on
the fact that like
what size could she have been like i'm a
size six and a half i could have been to
seven i could fit into a six
but i think just you know playing
devil's advocate
the whole dress and ensemble was made
like the magic
so like the magic made it like so
bespoke like literally
bit to a t and so i think that like no
one else has her exact
foot yeah as if it was like an imprint
yeah it was also as if the prince was
like blind because yes okay you could go
make everyone try on the shoe but you
you vaguely remember what she looks like
so if you're like literally making a
redhead try on she was like it's
obviously not her
yeah yeah obviously it wasn't bernadette
peters she had red curly hair right and
also bernadette peters was
was with jason alexander the whole night
right so like
the lack of logic was actually really
bothering me but
i understand that it's for children yeah
but like i think that it's like
rude to children to like it's insulting
to their intelligence i
couldn't agree more yeah but the
soundtrack was really what i showed up
for and i really forgot like that i knew
so many songs
the prince is giving a ball the prince
is giving a ball
the prince is giving a ball
stunning also in my own little corner
in my own little chair i can be
whatever i want to be
all at all it was like a fun little
movie it was stupid but
it was fun and honestly but that's on
cinderella like that's on
raw the storyline itself yeah i agree
like i don't know if it's a story and
it's like a
it's a disney story that keeps getting
retold and i feel like it's actually
really flawed in its
in its plot and maybe it's something we
re rework
right and also i think what i was
realizing last night like the story is
really only five
scenes and each of those scenes was
being like really stretched out
it's like there's you know the home
scene the ball
the shoe trying on and like that's it
yeah
but the wedding was stunning stunning
and the dre
the dress that whitney made both dresses
like
loved it it was really like epic to see
whitney houston on tv and i think it
just made me realize like i need to
watch the bodyguard because that's like
the movie that you know was like her big
acting debut yeah and she's just like so
stunning and like with her dramatic you
know sleeves and her hands like
cinderella no she's had the magic all
along everything of the sort
everything and she looked sickening in
that dress sickening and i could just
watch that scene like a million times of
like the carriage ride like that song is
so good
yeah impossible things are happening
every day
so all in all it was a good fun cute
choice i think next week i would like to
settle on something like a little more
um full if you know what i mean
yeah but again if you have
recommendations recommendations yes
please let us know i've so enjoyed this
and
that's our show and that's our week
that's our week and now we have our
interview with norma kamali so enjoy
that
get some inspiration heading into the
weekend perfect weekend energy like to
soak yourself up fill up your cup
and then your cup shell runeth over over
the weekend 100
so enjoy thank you norma kamali for
being here with us it was really really
cool to talk to you and we hope you guys
enjoy
the podcast we'll just continue with the
audio but if you're looking for the
video we actually recorded with her on
zoom
and she looked super cute so the video
is going to be up on our youtube yep
so check it out thank you guys so much
for listening to the morning toast the
millennial morning show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know every monday friday on youtube so
if you're watching us on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcast
can be found so spotify itunes stitcher
public radio i heart radio cast box all
the places so wherever you listen to
podcasts find us the morning toast and
leave a five star review about how
beautiful
stunning and smart we are hope you have
an amazing weekend you guys stay
safe if you're in the south in the texas
area stay
safe and we're thinking of you
yes we are have a great weekend you guys
bye